BASEBALL ANNOUOVINAME AND
MLB DRAFT OUT OFTL
THE REASONS E
A STATEMENT
AGUE BASEBAL
AMORTS VOTING  A AMERICANS AND
POSTRICT TOTONTINUES TO HAVE GA
UNWAVERING SUPPORT.
ADERS  TARGET, SNAPCT A PUBLIC
ELIGIBLE VOTERS THE RIGHT
COT NOW THE PRESIDENTND
JOHNSON. D
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THE PG STH AGOMING OUT A SAYING
THAUT EVERNEN.CANT
OU THINK
THIS DECISION Y MISSIONER OF ANT
PROTECH OUR DEMOCRACY.S HAVE TOE
YOU  SH
THIS INOCORPORATE AMERICA SHOUL
TOLERATE UNDERNI
DEMOCRACY  C
LEASEBALL AND CORPORATNS
WHO ARE STEPPING UP IN THIS
SOU A,
KNOW, SORT SIDES
SO
STE REPRESENTATIVEERRY AND
SHE TWEETED QUOTE, I
TEATED
INTENSELYTE
IGEOR
HOT LEAVE
GEORGIA.
THAT ONLY G
GIYOU THINK AT THIS POINT?LEO LL
>> WELL, WHEN YOU TA THEIGHT
TO VOTE FR WORKING GEO,
THAT'S WHAT HURT
ANYTHING
ENTERTAIN THAT BUSINS ACTIVITY
WHERE PEOPLE SO AT D IF W TRUE C
THE END OF THE D
THAN ANYTHIN IS SUBVERTING
OF DEMOCRACY, INDIVIDUALYITO S .
THAT'S WHAT HURTS MORE THAN
ANHI>>ED TO READT R OFSTATEMENT.
I KNOW'VT.IANS AND L THB'  DECI.
CHANCE
ING FOR
CT OYOUR LTS
INCLUDED.N THE STATE IS
PEIEITY OF ELECTIONS. BRUR
ATTEMPTED THEFT OF THE RIG
OR VOTE.NNOT HAVE AN INVERTEND
E STANDING UP ACT, THAT WAD
ORENACTIVITY OF THE
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNR OUR CONST.
HE PROCESS IA Y WHICH D BE ABLE.
WE FIGHT WARS TO ENSURE
DEMOY
WE SHOULD FIGHT HERE T
>>VEEWTHINGS IN THE LL RPOSEFULY
FOR EXAMPLE,ESTERDAY
BIDEN SHOULD LOOK  G
SIDE BDE
GIA HAS E
VOTIN DELAWARE  T.
A WSBOXED,ELE
DOEST HA T
THE THEM I20
THE PANDEMIC.IF THAT WILLTHTHER.
E HE SUNFAIR?AY TO KECHMP POINTS
>>S IS ABOHEF
GEORGIA, NOT ANY OF TH
.
HE SHOULD FOCU BGID SURE THE CO
TO?
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF FRAUD.
NF A
WE HAD A SYSTH CAR
OUT IN NOVEMBER FR COUNTINTHE B.